coming this summer
[Applause]
they're finally going to make a movie
about me the story of Batman's greatest
airline it's me that must be me and best
friend in the whole world
the movie is time to clean up this city
that actually does look pretty good
they're really making movies about every
superhero has there been a movie about
you it was a Green Lantern movie but we
don't we don't talk about that it's time
they make one about me I'm afraid it's
no I only make movies about real
superheroes I don't they take us
seriously Titans you guys are never
actually doing anything heroic that
wasn't even a crime and you didn't save
anything we say brutal design having a
movie is the only way to be seen as a
real hero what about an arch-nemesis
stop right there Deadpool Deadpool what
why does everybody think of Deadpool
I thought Deadpool was a good guy by the
way he should be saying that he's not me
okay cuz I came out like way before he
did no I'm pretty sure you're Deadpool
we can make you more arch-nemesis then
they will see that we're worthy of a
movie
I'm not interested in fighting a bunch
of sidekicks and a half a robot
[Music]
we're taking you down how are you gonna
do it we need a fart on me you want a
dance-off
you're gonna annoy me to death with your
waffles